[Music]
let's go to elizabeth in austin what's
up elizabeth
hey how you doing i'm good how are you
i'm hanging in there oh no what's going
on
well okay so i have a 10 month old son
um 34 years old and
and i had dated his father for
four months and
he revealed to me after that time that
he did two years in prison for
physically assaulting his ex-girlfriend
and i was starting to notice he was
being verbally abusive and starting to
throw things so i found out i was
pregnant unexpectedly
and i started to feel unsafe so i tried
to figure out how to get out of it so i
ended up telling him that i lost the
baby
oh
and so now you got to now that baby's 10
months old huh
so how can i help
um i mean i'm basically just like
wondering why i keep thinking about it
pretty much on a daily basis
um and i'm also worried about
when my son gets older you know what is
he gonna
i mean when he asked me where's my dad
at you know i don't know what to tell
him because i don't want to lie to him
so number one
um
okay i'm gonna i'm just gonna say all
the things out at the same time is that
okay
sure
um
as the father of a child
i can't imagine feeling like my
child and my safety were so much so that
i had to be on the run so every moment
you open your eyes because your body's
on the run you're on the run okay
you're hiding from someone that you're
scared of
and you're hiding from someone that is
you are now linked to
forever and um
yeah and
the safety of your kid so that's number
one
also as the father of two little kids
the thought that someone would hide a
child from me i can't like that creates
a rage it creates such an anger in me
that it's almost overwhelming right so
my first thought is like what do you
mean you didn't tell him like he doesn't
know he's got a kid right and i'm
balancing that with
yeah you weren't in that room john and
so i want to trust you elizabeth that
you're not safe and that you weren't
safe okay
um
and yeah there wasn't only that there
was other things as well you know
like what he lived he lived two and a
half hours away from me and um
he
fell asleep at the wheel at least twice
that i know of because we had a major
argument
the night that i ended up you know
wanting to break up with them and um he
had texted me about an hour and a half
later after we had the argument he's
like oh i i fell asleep again and went
into a ditch
and i'm like
i couldn't imagine him driving my baby
in the car and then falling asleep
because he at least done it twice as far
as i know
so so
100 i understand what you're saying okay
like i'm don't i'm not here to i'm not
i'm not shaming a mom keeping her baby
safe
and it's his baby too
right
so it's it's a mess it's just a mess is
what it is it's just an absolute mess
um
and then the third thing here to just
lob on top of all this is your instinct
is correct with the internet there is no
such thing as a kid who doesn't find out
yeah that happens sooner or later and if
if you're a parent who doesn't tell the
truth to him
not only does he find out who his dad is
he also
finds out mom
is tells lies
right and then he begins to wonder his
mom love me because she said that a lot
and his mom believed this and his mom do
right so it undermines the the sidewalk
with which he will walk on your son
and i don't know have you checked into
the legality of it i know it's state to
state states are different um
some states it's illegal to do what
you're doing other states it's like a
gray area it's only illegal if he wants
into the baby's life
and you prevent it but if you told them
that the baby's not around you see what
i'm saying
yeah
here's what i would do if i were you
i would
reach out to an attorney
and say here's what i've done here's why
i did it i need some some guidance
because right now you are flying blind
and that's keeping you up and that's
stressing you out
um
and
that stress is is being absorbed by that
little 10 month old
the true is that right
i mean i i guess what what's the what's
the possibility that you call this guy
and say hey i lied to you
you've got a 10 month old son um i want
you to sign full custody over to me
we're not getting back together i don't
want you to be a part of this baby's
life you have no interest in being like
would he say okay that sounds great or
would he start weeping and say i can't
believe i have a son i'm moving
i have no idea because he already moved
on he's got a girlfriend and she's got
two kids okay
um
well then it may be
she fights for custody right so who
knows what kind of mess this is gonna
turn into what you need is some security
and you don't have that right now
because you you took off
and i'm not blaming you for taking off
okay that's a whole other
like we're just dealing with where we
are right now your body's in fight or
flight because you were literally on the
run
and
until you get some stability you know
where you sit legally you know where you
sit when it comes to rights and
responsibilities when you know what you
have to do versus what you're what you
don't have to do
until you do that your body is going to
be running it's just revving in revenue
and reven
and you know as well as i do this is a
time bomb there's a reckoning at some
point
any time there's a reckoning coming i
like to just go get it done
with a team with a gang right
and what i say about reckoning there's a
mo there will come a time
when you have to face this man
and tell him that you hit his child from
him
i mean i didn't want to do that i i had
to think about it for at least a week
because i mean i knew it was
it's not what i wanted to do i i i know
i know that don't hear me shaming you
okay am i trying i'm not trying to
pile on okay
his reaction was hey you know
let's either give up the baby for
adoption
or get an abortion i didn't want to do
that i wanted to keep my baby that's
right
and i 100 applaud you so the chances of
him giving the baby up signing away
maybe like 99
right and maybe he gets a letter from an
attorney
that says we're you are the parent of
such and such and we are requesting full
custody et cetera um may be great
maybe signs that thing and then you
exhale
right
and then you tell that baby um was older
your daddy wasn't well
and um your son will have to live with
the fact that his dad didn't want
anything to do with his life
all right um so there's gonna be it's
gonna be hell to pay down the road
anyway what we don't want this baby to
to know is
dad left me and mom lied to me the whole
time or dad so badly wanted to be in my
life and mom hid him from me you know
and
a seven-year-old a 14 year old an 18
year old isn't gonna understand hey mom
found out dad was like a violent
criminal
and
he was starting to show signs of those
tendencies around me and i was pregnant
with you so i got us out of there to
keep us safe
that's something maybe a 21 year old 25
year old
um
you see what i'm saying so
the conversation's coming i'd much
rather you have an attorney you have all
the answers that you need have all the
things lined up
and all the paths forward
and you not live in fear of this day
coming whenever it's going to come
right
you will just sleep so much better even
if you get answers that you don't like
even if the attorney says i'm so sorry
but you gotta call that guy within 24
hours
yeah
at least you'll have some next step
because right now this your whole i mean
you're not sleeping are you
i mean
yeah i mean
because i i missed i moved so yeah i i
i'm saying i'm saying it more
metaphorical but yes
just fine like a baby and hey maybe
that's the case maybe that's the case
maybe like no dude i don't know what
you're talking about i did the right
thing i'm never getting to feel a second
of bad about it i did what was right
um but you wouldn't be calling me
i mean i feel like i did what i had to
do to keep my son safe but if not
ultimately what i wanted i would have
liked to stay with him if he hadn't been
violent you know
absolutely he hasn't been yelling at me
all the time yes and you're gonna have
to grieve that
right because
the dream we have is to have kids and
have this little home on the picket
fence and the dog and the camping trips
like
that picture's not going to happen here
right and so
there will come a moment when we have to
grieve that that comes after you're safe
and right now you're still alone you're
still not registering as safe
mm-hmm
you're on the run
so will you reach out to an attorney
yeah i will okay let's call a local
family attorney and say i need to set up
a consultation and
just sit down and do not please don't go
in there and not tell the whole truth
tell everything that happened all of the
truth
um don't hide anything don't put
anything in a drawer like this is
everything husband's not safe he was
passing out behind the wheel
he was um
raising his voice he was throwing us
around he was pushing whatever was going
on um tell the truth
and then they'll walk you through what
comes next
i'm sorry
i hate this for you i hate this for that
little baby i even hate it for dad i
hate it for everybody it's a mess it's a
mess
but the day of that conversation will
come so let's have that conversation on
your terms
with all the facts and data that you
have and somebody like an attorney on
your side
whenever it all comes down